welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition aka your friendly
neighborhood spoiler man and a lot of
leaks have just broken the internet
about the Black Widow movie these were
posted by someone who has apparently
seen the film and it stands as the first
review of the movie this video will be
covering what happens in the post
credits scene who taskmaster really is
and what the user thought of the overall
film there's tons and tons of spoilers
in it
so if you don't want anything about the
movie potentially ruined that I highly
recommend that you turn off now
as with all leaks these should be taken
with a pinch of salt but they do line up
with prior leaks and you know we don't
like to report on stuff unless we're
sure there's a lot of truth to it last
year we got right the final episode of
Game of Thrones the full Joker movie
Avengers endgame rise of Skywalker and
Terminator dark fate so I wouldn't want
to ruin my reputation as the worst
person on the internet and get this
wrong anyway take that as you will and
without the way I just want to give a
huge thank you for clicking this video
now let's get into our breakdown of the
Black Widow spoilers ok so the review
comes from an anonymous user on 4chan
that says they were part of a focus
group that was shown the film they
didn't know in advance what it would be
but this is the movie that they got to
see some effects were not fully finished
but it gave an overall feeling of the
entire film the user said that they were
pleasantly surprised by the movie and
that it's basically a Mission Impossible
sequel with Black Widow replacing Ethan
Hunt they said it works better than
you'd expect and in regards to the plot
there are apparently a lot of
similarities according to the user Widow
has been excommunicated and is being
hunted by the government she has to do
the usual get this thing so that life
can go back to normal
oh no there's a grander conspiracies
save the world give the thing to your
sister deal with the consequences and
peace out that thing is a flash drive
which pops up in the post-credits scene
but yeah that was their plot summary in
a nutshell we now know that the Robert
Downey jr. scene is right at the
beginning of the movie and this pretty
much kick-starts the entire thing it
opens with Tony Stark telling Natasha
that
to breaking the sokovia accords that the
government is gonna come after are
harder than the other Avengers because
of a history they know she's dangerous
they know she has the ability to go
rogue and will fight to the death by any
means necessary
this warning from Stark helps her get a
head start and it's from here that she
travels to Budapest which is where the
movie predominantly takes place the user
said all of the action involving the
skull guy who they think is taskmaster
but they don't know because he doesn't
have a name in a movie was dope as hell
they then went on to say that he is
Black Widows X which is obvious but it's
pulled off well enough the 4chan writer
clarified this later in the review by
saying that the character was OT [ __ ] Ben
Lee whose name always get wrong and this
also lines up with earlier leaks that
said the characters were one in the same
for those of you who don't know
taskmaster is actually a master martial
artist that is able to mimic his
opponents moves massively this makes him
almost impossible to fight and he can
pretty much counter everything that he
throw at him now if you look at the
upcoming merchandise for the film it may
be possible that the character has
already started copying some of the big
names in the MCU one of the Funko pops
of the character has very similar
gauntlets to Black Panther so he could
have taken his style of combat from the
character he of course has a bow and
arrow similar to Hawkeye and one of the
helmets of the villain shows that he has
a visor with scanners on and an AI
system that could be very similar to
Iron Man's I'm guessing all of his stuff
was made in China because it all looks
like cheap knockoffs of Consular not our
Chinese overlords not on a Disney review
I'm just kidding China I love you you
pretty much made everything in my house
anyway so yeah thank you very much
anyway back to the review the user said
that Rachel Weis is the big bad of it
all and that Florence Pugh and
taskmaster are both working for general
Ross this yet again lines up with leaks
that made their way to the internet last
year and though it is possible that the
user could have just scoured the
Internet piecing this all together it
does at least mirror what we've heard so
far whilst they praised the film in a
lot of ways that doesn't mean it was an
overly positive review the user said
that David Harbor was the worst part of
the movie and that he was super cheesy
and forced to deliver quips non-stop
that didn't really
they said that red guardian who Harbor
plays dies during the movie and though
it's played four tears it was actually a
welcome goodbye they complimented the
action for most of the movie saying that
a lot of the hand-to-hand fights all
worked well and felt real and grounded
however the user said that like most MCU
movies the N is just non-stop CGI that
there is a big helicopter onslaught that
is just a mess of effects we do know
that there's going to be a big
helicopter part in the film due to the
toys and so on so yeah this is going to
be happening for the finale of the movie
walton goggins also has a cameo as well
as Nick Fury and Hawkeye which we'll get
into in just a bit the user said that
some of the cameos work a little better
than others and that the opening with
Robert Downey jr. felt a bit like layer
in the rise of Skywalker which is funny
because because he's not dead in real
life but I just found that a bit funny
he also said there's a recurring joke
about a chest of drawers that's
hilarious
I don't know what the joke is but I do
know a good one about a chest of drawers
I said said wait wait for it I said I
put crucifixes on a chest of drawers and
now it's a crossdresser hey ya bin that
hit that subscribe button gon hit it
anyway the user said they didn't hate
the film and they gave it a six point
five out of ten so yeah a pretty good
score I think for the casual viewer
that's what I would expect them to write
it as they didn't seem that
knowledgeable about the MCU and kept
calling taskmaster skull guy so maybe if
you're a more hardcore fan of the film
then it'll be a lot better and I'm
really looking forward to it
the user then went on to answer
questions about the post-credits scene
which we'll get into in just a bit
before we go through that though I just
want to let you know we're giving away a
free copy of dr. sleep to one random
subscriber all you have to do to be in
with a chance of winning is like the
video subscribe to the channel and leave
your thoughts and the black widow news
in the comments section below the
winners gonna be chosen at random on the
15th of February in the cell be shipped
out from then Tova gets the prize it's
the best of luck to everyone who takes
part okay so the film closes out with
two post credits scenes that both take
place after the events of Avengers
endgame the first one follows Florence
pews character Yelena and a taskmaster
who are meeting with general Ross
the flash drive that is the big
MacGuffin of the film Ross tells them
that the gist getting started and then
they cut to black on a tease of the
thunderbolts now this lines up a lot
with behind the scenes images that we
saw up William Hurt and which he'd been
clearly aged up he looks old
hella old so it looks like he survived
the snap and then aged normally from the
events of infinity war I did a full
video on this and did get some people
saying that maybe he's just old in real
life but yeah they've clearly applied
makeup his herd didn't look like this at
all in 2019 when they were putting
together the film the Royal Room is that
Ross will go on to be the Red Hulk and
that Thunderbolts will be the next film
with the characters but according to the
user
this doesn't confirm or deny it however
due to Ross's age and his affiliation
and well study of the Hulk you can see
how he would think that this is a chance
at the Fountain of Youth that will save
him from the frailty and old age that
he's now suffering from the Thunderbolts
are a big part of the Marvel Universe
and I'm glad that taskmaster survives as
he is a character that is a big linchpin
of things so yeah he deserves more
movies as the character the final
credits scene is the cameo of Jeremy
Renner and once more this takes place
after endgame the user said that they
could tell it was the present because he
was all tied up hope I hope he has the
best haircut ever to be put in a movie
because we definitely talked the scene
doesn't ease a return of Natasha and it
actually seems that it closes the book
on the character with Hawkeye being
stood at a grave with his kids so yeah
if these leaks are true we won't be
getting a return of ScarJo unless unless
of course the movie makes three billion
dollars or something and they realize
they need her back personally though I
think the door is always open to
resurrect her as she died on Boromir and
no Hulk tried to bring her back if we
did bring her back to life she would
still be stuck on that planet we also
know that Steve returned the soul stone
so he may have been able to trade it for
a sacrifice we don't know for definite
but yeah there are a couple of things
that can leave the door open for her to
come back but as of now if these leaks
are true it doesn't look like she'd be
back anytime soon I did I just want to
happy ending for her and hope that's all
I want really I'm pretty happy with how
the film sounds though and it seems to
have a lot going for it
and yeah lots of nice cameos reveals and
it sets up some good things for the
future who knows one of the unannounced
films of phase four may be Thunderbolts
so yeah fingers crossed for that now
obviously I'd love to hear your thoughts
on the leaks and if you think that you
are not coming below and let me know and
if you enjoy this video then please give
it a thumbs up and make sure you check
out our breakdown of the behind the
scenes information that we have on the
Batman which is gonna be linked at the
end we go over all of the news stories
and updates so it's definitely worth
checking out if you want to know more
you can support the show by subscribing
to us and patreon and if you want to
come chat to us after the video you can
join our discord server in the
description below or follow us on
twitter at definition whitey that's the
best way to keep up to date with
everything we do it having spoilers and
hopefully we see over there very soon
this is a channel for people who are
super into superheroes so if that's the
kind of thing you like hit subscribe
thank you for taking the time to watch
this
I've been definition you've been the
best I'll see you next time take care
peace
[Music]
[Music]
you